brought to you by Assassin's Creed Unity
make history with friends available
now hey guys my name is Jess McDonald
today is November 11 and you're watching
Gamespot
news two wildly awesome universes are
colliding and we finally have some news
about it here's everything you probably
want to know about tell Tales Game of
Thrones The Walking Dead developer has
said that the game will tell the story
of house Forester explaining caught up
in the events of the war of the five
Kings they're placed in a precarious
position where members of the household
must do everything they can to prevent
the house from meeting its Doom the
events of the game will begin toward the
end of season 3 of the TV series and
you'll encounter familiar locations like
King's Landing as well as a bunch of new
ones the Foresters a cannon to the
fiction envisioned by Author George RR
Martin and you'll be playing from five
different perspectives Telltale have
explained that the actions of one
character can affect everyone else the
first episode iron from Ice is due out
by the end of the year on basically all
the non- Nintendo platforms including
iOS Just Cause 3 is officially coming to
PC Xbox One and PS4 next year Avalanche
Studios have announced through a game in
former cover reveal that the rumors are
indeed true and the open world game is
in development Game Informer reports
that parachute and grapple mechanics
have been improved from 2010's Just
Cause 2 and the game features a sweet
new wing suit you'll be able to suit up
with all that equipment As You Adventure
through the fictional Mediterranean
archipelago which serves as the game
setting and now for some resolution
whatnot next month's Halo 5 multiplayer
beta will be in
720p before you freak out and been your
pre-order 343 have said that that is not
the final resolution for the game 343
industry Studio head Josh Holmes has
explained for the beta at this point
we're totally focused on gameplay we're
Midway through development we're
balancing and tuning the gameplay
systems all of the Polish and
optimization graphically is stuff that
typically comes toward the end of a
production cycle if you join in on the
beta that kicks off December 29 at least
you can be confident in the knowledge
that it will run at 60 FPS as part of
Halo Fest we also got a glimpse of the
multiplayer in action which you can
check out on Gamespot as for your
question of the day let me know if you
reckon the Halo 5 beta multiplayer being
at 720p matters or not if you're after
more stories you can head to Gamespot
where we've got bits and pieces on Final
Fantasy 13 and our reviews of Dragon Age
Inquisition and Assassin's Creed Unity
those are all the things I wanted to
tell you about today but be sure to
check back with me same time tomorrow
subscribe to us and I'll catch you
[Music]
later